foreign
[Music]
drifting like a 1974 dressing like the
Rolling Stones hey ho let's go get some
more like young Ramon
some nights feel like every night this
one feels brand new
things on my mind
[Music]
champions
flow
[Music]
s
dreaming like it's 1984 dancing like a
talk yes that's called 40s at the corner
store to take to bed
tell me that you need me
ask me what the hell
[Music]
away
foreign
[Music]
of champagne
foreign
[Music]
watching that flow as much as I enjoyed
creating it this is a really fun
experiment to be a little bit more
interactive with y'all out there and
give you the keys to be able to drive
the car and tell me what songs you want
to see me flow out to so if you could
leave me a comment let me know did you
enjoy this as well and also let me know
what songs should be on my playlist for
February I would love to hear from you
in the meantime this video would not be
possible if not for the kind support of
all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people who sit down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support if you out there
watching love the content that I make
and you want to support me in doing it
here are three ways that you can do that
number one you can go sign up to support
the channel over at patreon.com
drexfactor POI there's a whole host of
awesome rewards that are available up
there take your pick of them and and uh
thank you in advance for checking that
out number two if you would like to take
some of my online courses those are
available over at
learn.drexfactor.com I've got everything
from a beginner course to a beyond the
basics course to a whole bunch of
advanced courses as well so you can go
check that out as well and finally I
offer live stream classes through
crowdcast they meet every Tuesday night
so to sign up for either the current or
next class you can go to crowdcast.io
drexfactor and see what's currently
available do bear in mind that all those
classes get recorded so you can watch
them whenever you want if you'd like to
see more videos of me flowing out I will
go ahead and leave a link to a playlist
of said videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thank you so much for watching
thank you so much to everybody who voted
on the song that I flowed out to and
make sure that you yourself get outside
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon peace